[Music]
then listening to the the Zelo app and
the things and the people that are
calling out could need help you know and
you're hearing about the kids and women
and people been stranded for days I mean
it just really tugs at you just heard
about rescue crews during hurricane
Harvey using Zelo an app that lets
people turn their smartphones into
virtual walkie-talkies such technology
wasn't even around when a major
hurricane last hit Florida but in the
days ahead some of these apps could
literally save lives
CNET senior editor Dan Ackerman joins us
to explain Dan talk to us about Zelo to
start with how's that work that's become
really popular over the last couple of
weeks it's basically it's a
voice-over-ip app but it feels a lot
like those will push-to-talk phones
people used to have where you could get
an instant connection to somebody
because the setup is easy and the
interface is easy and you get the direct
voice communication people found it very
useful if those quick voice
communications with other people give us
an idea of a few other apps that are
really important at this time for people
to have no obviously weather apps are
very important the Weather Channel has a
separate hurricane app that has a lot of
really useful information
besides weather alerts which you can get
a lot of places that have a really
detailed radar and I like that their
radar map goes into the future you can
play a little predictive video of where
the storm is going to go so I go ahead
in
yeah then Weather Underground is another
weather site and they also have a
hurricane app they use a lot of
crowd-sourced data from people with
weather stations at home and that's
really useful to get another data point
and their radar maps have a lot of
levels of intricacy to them you can add
wind speed you can add lightning you can
add a lot of different details that you
want to see for where you are what is
this thing you brought with you here
then this is something I've actually had
since Hurricane sandy here in New York
it's a radio it's from Eaton and it's
solar powered it's battery-powered you
can use a hand crank if you if you have
to and it's got a powered USB port in
the back so you can charge your phone
from it and if you have no power you
crank it's like a minute you get at
least half an hour of radio use a lot of
people are so concerned with keeping
things charged like their phones you say
keep a laptop fully charged another
lesson I learned here in New York during
hurricane sandy was if you have
especially an old laptop sitting around
and the storm is coming keep it plugged
in keep the battery charged and then
even if you never turn the laptop on
it's basically a gigantic battery pack
that you can use to get several charges
out of your phone or for several
people's phones
by using the USB ports in it keeping
getting good information in the middle
of a storm like this can be very
difficult what's some of the best way to
do that
you know FEMA has an app that has a lot
of updates and it has a lot of tips and
it has a lot of access to disaster
preparedness sites and it even gives you
a way to apply for additional help later
the Red Cross has a lot of apps they
have a specific hurricane app that has a
map of shelter the real time map you can
you pinch to zoom in on it sounds like
if people just get out there and start
looking for some of these things like
the Red Cross app that they can find
more information that way Dan Ackerman
thank you we appreciate it thank you and
stay with CBS News throughout the
weekend for extensive coverage of
hurricane
will have special reports throughout the
day on the network and on our streaming
service CBS n then tomorrow we'll have a
special edition of CBS this morning with
Charlie Nora and Gail beginning at 7:00
Eastern followed by Sunday morning and
Face the Nation